savez vous que sur un litre de carburant
à 1 euros 81 euros de taxes donc nous
sommes le pays qui taxent ont le plus
juste avant malte je crois donc il ya un
réel problème aujourd'hui tard ça
remplit les caisses de l'état plus
besoin
le principe qui consiste à beaucoup
taxer pour donner sous forme de chèque
il ya quelque chose qui ne fonctionne
pas sur le plan du simple bon sens et
donc nous nous avons posé effectivement
cet objectif du litre de carburant à 1
euro 50 vous savez dans les zones
rurales dont je suis par exemple une
élue on n'est pas forcément de gros
rouleurs puisque le ministre le maire a
posé le principe d'une est différenciée
pour les gros rouleurs mais les gens
prennent leur voiture tous les jours et
ça pèse véritablement beaucoup sur le
pouvoir d'achat donc nous nous disons
c'est une façon aussi de poser le débat
moins de taxes - au moins publiquement
et est plutôt que d'un coup par coup à
un coût de chèques qui ne résolvent pas
durablement la cité